regarder les étoiles filantes ont vite
et bien vous fasse
il ya quinze ans on m'a appelé pour
doubler un dessin animé
je n'avais jamais entendu parler puisque
c'était le premier épisode qui
s'appelait donc l'âge de glace et on m'a
confié ce rôle de diego en français et
récemment je me suis demandé quand est
ce que j'avais commencé en fait on m'a
annoncé que le premier était en 2002
donc ça commence à faire
il ya des enfants qui ont dû grandir
avec nos voix dans ses personnages
je n'arrête pas d'imaginer notre enfant
il sort est le plus beau du monde
il s'est tu vois un peu de félins peu
gracieux mais un peu manche par moments
ça s'est imposé assez vite peut-être sur
le premier épisode on a mis un petit peu
plus de temps mais maintenant à chaque
fois que je reviens dans studio et que
je me mets devant le micro ça revient
assez vite d'autant plus que entre temps
il ya des enfants qui me demandent de la
faire dans la vraie vie
du coup je la perds jamais de vue kokou
les enfants je trouve qu'il a pris un
petit peu en sympathie parce que l'étude
était toujours un peu en train de râler
là il reste toujours signer mais il est
plus impliqué on sent que d'avoir
rencontré cette jeune tigre est cela
fait du bien
les chants gris lama va vous dressez
vous voir
sur le show et ça c'est le gars qui va
nous sauver la vie c'est vrai qu'à
l'époque du premier épisode j'étais un
petit peu au stade de mon personnage
aujourd'hui c'est à dire qu'il avait des
envies de paternité
donc dans l'espoir d'avoir des enfants
je me suis dit je vais commencer à faire
des voix de dessins animés comme ça je
pourrais plaire à mes futurs enfants
je sais mais pourquoi peut-être bien que
sur le vélo 6 6 le sis a lieu eh bien je
serai le père de deux petits tigres
rooney l'a fait je crois qu'il m'a
vraiment pris pour un gant c'est une
fierté de faire partie de la saga du
dessin animé qui a eu le plus de suite
ça prouve que les gens ont continué à
avoir envie de le voir que les
personnages sont solides
non c'est fantastique s'est réalisé le
mien aussi